[Music]
so start in 2011 Samsung releases a
series of commercials titled the next
big thing it turns out that the next big
thing was a smartphone too big for your
hand to hold now with more megapixels
how disappointing so don't get me wrong
I actually love my smartphone it's
arguably the most useful piece of
technology ever invented
but even the smartphone can be disrupted
it must be and it probably will be so we
don't have much time so with you a 10
second history on computers we had
massive computers the size of this room
that nobody could afford then we had
computers on our desks that most could
afford now we have computers in our
pockets that almost anyone can afford
the smartphone today represents
ubiquitous computing but in this
shrinking process haven't we also lost
something we're now sucked into our
technology and our addiction has
isolated us even when we're with other
people their smartphone today reduces
presence so we must demand that the next
generation computer break this trade-off
between ubiquity and presence I'm gonna
make the case today that the real next
big thing is a our augmented reality or
as many of you know it Pokemon go what
you may not know about AR is that you
actually already know AR it's been in
our sci-fi fantasy since we were kids
it's c-3po and Chewie playing hollow
chess and Star Wars
it's Tony Stark inventing iron man in
free form space with his hands but it's
always just been sci-fi that all changed
for me in October of 2014 when a company
that nobody had ever heard of called
magic leap and
that they had raised a half billion
dollars to build augmented reality that
was the first time that I thought
augmented reality might become part of
our reality their jobs paid at the time
was titled Wizards wanted and in that
moment I knew I had to become a wizard I
was lucky enough to spend my past summer
internship at magic leap honing my
wizardry and I can't tell you what I saw
down there they're a very secretive
company but that next big thing
I believe it's coming so many of you
have probably read about heard about
this concept AR VR
right and I hate this and so the first
thing we're gonna do is remove the dam
slash VR virtual reality looks like this
it's a headset and it's an immersive
experience you can swim through the
ocean you can fly through space it
blocks out all outside light in order to
remove you from where you are it blocks
out so much outside light that you might
not notice that a Mark Zuckerberg is
walking right by you I do believe that
VR has a firm place in our technology
future but it does not solve the problem
the whole point is removing you from
your current world taking your presence
and placing it elsewhere
augmented reality AR on the other hand
keeps you firmly grounded in your
current world you see what you would
normally see with your eyes but now
augmented with digital images so real
that they blend seamlessly into your
environment right now
AR is early it's mostly on your
smartphone it's actually pretty silly
but the destination that it's ultimately
headed what people are so excited about
is smart glasses
what has AR enthusiasts so pumped is
that same portability of your smartphone
but looking up
again unbounded from the tiny glass
rectangles that tend to draw our
attention under the table what we're so
excited about is reimagining our digital
lives back into the space around us AR
is already a cool technology but what
will make it an important technology is
breaking that trade-off between ubiquity
and presence solving that smartphone
problem so to make it real let's imagine
a day in the life with a computer on
your head your alarm clock will go off
like it normally does but instead of
reaching for your smart phone you'll
grab your smart glasses and instead of
squinting it tiny emails on your screen
they'll inhabit the space right in front
of you you're self driving uber will
pick you up for work of course its
self-driving and it's got a are built
right into the dash so you can finally
check Twitter on the way to work and see
how late you'll be to work at work you
have my dream job you design motorcycles
and you're working on the latest ride
right in front of you with your hands
you're old-school to monitor setup isn't
quite doing it for you you need a little
more screen real estate
so you'll whip up a new screen the size
of the wall the snap of your fingers you
end the day in a global design meeting
with leaders across the world or in this
case across the galaxy
at home your dinner recipe will float
right in front of you so you won't have
to use your hands and get marinara sauce
all over your dirty iPad and then
finally in the future you don't own a TV
anymore because you can just put one on
any wall in your home I could go on but
AR is gonna be a big part of your life
from the moment you wake up to the
moment you go to bed it's gonna be on
the go in the office in the home and
eventually everyone isn't going to have
it so usually when I talk about AR which
if you ask my friends is all the time I
hear one of two reactions the first is a
that kind of freaks me out and it should
technology paradigm shifts always come
with growing pains and AR will be no
different we're gonna have to grapple
with real privacy issues like facial
recognition and the fear of Big Brother
we're gonna have to build a world we're
not every street corner is a digital
dystopian marketing hellhole like Times
Square we're gonna have to make sure
that we don't just take the distraction
from under the table and move it into
our peripheral vision ultimately
technology's win when the good outweighs
the bad
and for AR there is so much good it's
gonna make us better informed putting
contextual information right in our line
of sight it's gonna make learning better
pulling information off the page and
making it interactive and collaborative
it's already making business more
efficient giving workers live
instructions it's already saving lives
putting medical information right in
front of surgeons the second thing that
I usually hear is whoa that's pretty
cool but isn't that like ten years away
and the answer here is maybe but a lot
of really smart people think that it's
coming a lot sooner we're still gonna
have to fix
the whole helmet problem and turn it
into a form factor that looks a lot more
like a stylish pair of Warby Parker's we
still don't know exactly how we're going
to control it right now we have things
like these super ugly controllers that
you see with VR we're eventually gonna
need to use our hands our eyes our voice
but these challenges are being worked on
today by really really smart people
optimists think that an early Apple
product will be out in 2018 this year or
next Tim Cook has gone on the record
saying we believe augmented reality is
going to change the way we use
technology forever
I actually think wired put it best they
said that a secret AR Manhattan Project
is one of those things that every
self-respecting tech oligarch must have
these days the point is that the
Facebook's and the apples and the
googles of the world are already working
on this in fact in February alone we saw
a ton of activity pokemons go bought
another AR startup magically partnered
with the NBA this week actually
magically raised a half billion
additional round Intel instead of
processors announced smart glasses and
the New York Times actually covered the
Olympics in augmented reality the point
is this is coming really soon so if I've
convinced you at all that this is going
to be big and exciting and hear me out
AR is going to need leaders it's gonna
need talent like you it's got big
challenges to solve but even bigger
opportunity like the smartphone the PC
the internet waves that came before it
it will upend entire industries would
you have missed those but let's return
to why it's not just exciting but it's
also important it's going to be better
for us as humans
if you believe like me that the gravity
of technology has pulled us further away
from the people that really matter if
you believe that there shouldn't have to
be this trade-off between ubiquity and
presence if you believe that technology
can actually help us end our isolation
from the world then a our needs you
technologies like this come around once
every generation and we don't have that
many shots on goal to get them right
I believe that AR is our chance to look
each other back in the eye again so
let's go build the next big thing
[Music]